le monde c'est ce plaisir juste pour
vous dire dans la vidéo que
malheureusement il ya eu un fail au
montage en effet de vendre un gros stade
le mot sur la droite comme d'habitude et
là en fait j'avais fait le montage et je
me suis aperçu en retournant pour
modifier des trucs que j'avais supprimé
la vidéo de ma tête sans faire exprès
donc la vidéo qui va suivre vous ne
verrez pas la tête alors que vous étiez
censé l'avoir essayé dommage parce que
j'étais en mode génère donc c'est un
petit peu mal au bon temps mais je pense
que c'est vrai quand même en tout cas du
coup soyez indulgents merci beaucoup et
puis bonne vidéo on se retrouve demain
pour de nouvelles normes en jurant des
vacances de vente de devises et à
bientôt
je donne s'excuse et l'on se retrouve
aujourd'hui sur star wars kinect et là
j'ai lancé une course à lancôme en
direct dans la course 1 mais il ya des
éléphants des vaisseaux des femmes nus
de femmes nues pardon j'ai peur je pense
encore beaucoup trop à bikini car tu
planes
alors j'ai choisi un perso méga d'arc je
suis pas sur la loi allégeant avait
commencé j'ai envie de commencer la
course devrait jamais faire un jeu des
corps de jonathan boulet gens à elle est
répugnant sur le vélo pour jouer yes à
laisser partir à faire cette course on
va gagner me donne un bon paquet de
thunes et on va tous acheter des glaces
bon allez on y est on des bras et
attraper les commandes pour commencer au
plus tard ouattara j'ai mal commencé
excusez moi c'est vrai show la nasa pour
les attrape
je vous rassure on les rattrape mais non
mais non mais non
non non mais bordel à teaneck la 20e
place entre des côtes tout va bien vous
abreuver ils sont là ils sont là à l'égo
de goût allez je suis sûr qu'on peut le
faire les gens attend souvent pas mûres
pièces comme ça t'affecte je comprends
pas trop ce qui se passe mais ça se
passe quand même aller les défis de
piloter ce match est un bordel c'est
comme si en plus on touchait pas un truc
à savoir troisième bien franchement
c'est pas mal où sont les marchands de
glace
maintenant je pense qu'on a fait une
partie de ses actifs liés patel de danse
galactique mari qui aurait besoin de
réparations quelque part oui oui ma
kinect jamais nos voiles d'espoir et non
en fait ça a remis d'une façon
m
c'est en seconde on trouve sortie
exactement bon on est chaud c'est tout
en en flammes la piste de nous fait
danser du tube take two pas à attendre
moi j'ai trois étoiles moi j'ai trois
étoiles bon ton mais moi je viens du
light avec des gros pectoraux les
muscles un sabre il ya bien longtemps
dans une galaxie lointaine très
lointaine musique maintenant
approché par bahwan ou chose coupe de
cheveux on apprend quelque chose ok ok
comment est ce la pète
amatrice pour faire la technique j'étale
que 1768 jeu fallait regarder je fends
l'air avec un soutien trop bien pour
saab alors moi je veux juste que des
patates pourquoi tiens tiens moi je te
fais attaque attaque mortuaire il va
voir il va comprendre que tout patron
mais
tiens oui on est super finale à bientôt
tu vas chez à paris janssen ouvre mais
des bandes noires la couleur quelque
chose due forme elle fait partie m tu
pars aux joies
l'investiture non moi je